around 16 hours and positive cases have
gone missing from the test and trace
data
why should people have confidence in the
ability to track the virus if you can't
even track the data
well what happened here paul was that
there was uh
some of the data it got truncated and
and it was lost but what they've
done now is uh not only contacted all
the people
who were identified as having the
disease i mean that that was done
in the first place but they're now
working through all the contacts as well
and
the key thing i would say is that and it
goes for everybody
is that if you're contacted by nhs
tests and trace then you must
self-isolate if you if you're told
you've been in contact with somebody
who has the virus you must sell five
states there is support
uh of 500 for doing so and of course a
10 000 pound
fine if you don't does the government
have any idea how many people should
have been traced who haven't been traced
because of this data makes up
i can't give you those those figures but
what i can say is that uh
all those people are obviously being
contacted and the key
thing is as i say that everybody whether
in this group or or generally should
should self isolate that's the way to
make it work uh
500 pounds if you uh if you do per week
and a 10 000 pound fine if you don't and
what that does
is it it creates a fire break around the
uh
the incident and uh and helps us to
fight the virus
do you worry that given once you add in
these positive cases the number of cases
rising faster than we initially thought
perhaps the restrictions you've
introduced
aren't having the kind of effect that
you'd hoped they'd have
i think that's a very good question but
you know
actually the the the incidence that
we're seeing
in the cases really sort of corresponds
to pretty much where we thought
uh we were and to be frank i think that
the slightly lower numbers that we'd
seen
uh you know didn't really reflect where
we thought the disease was likely to go
so
uh i think it's these numbers are
realistic
uh the the crucial thing is that in the
next few days
week we'll we'll see more clearly
whether
some of the restrictions that we've put
in the extra enforcement
uh of of the rule of six the the extra
enforcement
of self-isolation the rules on on mars
and so on all the stuff that has come in
i will see whether that starts to work
in in driving down the
the virus but you know this is all very
much
in our hands collectively as a country
if we follow that basic guidance and we
all know what it is but it can't be
repeated often enough hand space
hands face space get a test if you have
symptoms
self-isolated contacted and so on you
know
then i've no doubt that we will be able
to get on top of it as indeed
we did earlier this year there is now a
complex patchwork of local restrictions
in place
when will the government be making an
announcement on simplifying that perhaps
the three-tier traffic light
type system well one of the difficulties
in fighting the pandemic is you keep
having to
adjust the strokes you play the shots
you play
depending on on where the virus is and
and
the effect it's having in different
localities and
it's certainly true as as chris whitty
and others have said that
it seems more localized this time than
it was in
uh in in march and april that's that's
how it has been anyway
uh and we will be taking steps as you
can imagine constantly to
to keep guidance keep advice as simple
as we can when there's more to say on
that i will certainly be saying it but
for now it's you know follow the local
rules
in the areas which under under special
restrictions get on the website
to look at what you need to do but
generally it's it's
all the restrictions that you know but
is it your intention to simplify the
system with a three-tier approach
well we want to keep the system as as
simple as possible
in terms of a vaccine lastly prime
minister is it the case that everyone
should
expect to be able to get hold of that
vaccine if and when it is available
well we don't yet have a vaccine
unfortunately
but we're working very very hard to get
one
i went to see the the scientists at
oxford of the edward jenner
institute the astrazeneca team
incredible what they're doing you know
you really feel that they
they must be on the verge of it but you
know it's got to be properly tested it's
got to be
properly validated and
we're not there yet obviously if and
when we
we get a vaccine then the the crucial
thing would be to ensure that we have
sufficient supplies
in this country that we're able to make
it in this country
distribute it fast in this country and
clearly the uh the priority for a
vaccine will be
uh as i think kate bingham and others
have said will be those who
are uh the most vulnerable groups that
will be the that's how you'd start
okay prime minister thank you